I mentioned I used the hpilora program and right and it started passing five inch worms. I saved and took it to my doctor. He said look like a scaris roundworm. Oh, how fun is that I bought five boxes of your friend bed is all he gave me a script for our bed is all two pills, is there a difference.
You know, I don't you don't have to Google that search that I'm not familiar. I think it's the same product. This is just the fenbenazole is the name of the product that is used for animals.
This is the human form and it's probably a much higher dose.
That's the difference.
The fenbenazole boxes that we sell in our store are for a 10 pound dog that is a cancer treatment that really a parasite treatment, even though it's a parasite pill to off label use of that medication over the counter so we feel free to sell it.
That's really the different does my whole family, including the dog need to be treated.
But really, if it is a roadworm, it is really passed through feces in contact with feces hpilora itself is different.
It's not a tapeworm. It's not a tapeworm. It's small little parasite.
And it is passed through oral transmission as well. So if you kissed your kids, you could pass.
Hpilora. So that we're not talking about it. It's pilarial. So no, but in the case of Hpilora, then yes, you do want to work on creating the whole family, putting this family pets, but not what's wrong with.
So my wife is killing them. Do you still say it's best to take that fenbenazole.
Make sure they are all gone. Love to know your thoughts on this before I start.
Yeah, I, you know, I would not feel bad about taking a medication as well as doing the parasite program, the hpilora program, I don't think this one will take you that.
If you have a pair of clear, you could try that. I mean, if you're afraid of side effects of this medication that is recommended, because it is much higher dose.
I'm sure that the fenbenazole boxes, you could try just doing the fenbenazole boxes instead doing a much, much lower dose. You might have just as good a results.